omicron suddenly changed everything
the coronavirus variant shifted the
focus to boosters restricted travel and
more home testing
few governments are eager to return to
the blanket lockdowns that rob so many
people of their livelihoods
so what's the answer
measures are becoming more targeted in
some countries non-essential shops and
recreational venues are off bounds for
the unvaccinated
[Music]
pandemic dynamics whatever the measures
it's the timing that counts
[Music]
i'm ben fazoulen hi it's a balancing act
the right measures to protect our lives
and our livelihoods even the countries
we thought were handling this pandemic
so well are struggling to get the
balance right like south korea
yu yun suk angela and her husband run a
restaurant in a new development on the
outskirts of seoul when covet 19 struck
and restrictions on customers and
opening hours were imposed she cut
overhead and prepared for the long haul
[Music]
my husband wanted to open a restaurant
so we started a barbecue place this is a
good spot but it got tough when corona
hit out of nowhere
we reduced staff but we're still
struggling doing our best for our
customers
i hope the government supports small
businesses with more rational measures
merchants are subject to fines and
closures if protocols are not followed
and most people have now largely
accepted the inconveniences wearing
masks and digitally signing in
especially for the elderly it's not easy
to use qr codes so they got mad at me
sometimes
but now a lot of people can use them and
it's getting easier
almost becoming a way of life
in november the government started its
living with covid19 policy easing social
distancing measures after vaccinations
were up and covered cases down
but they may not have been cautious
enough covet 19 here has surged to new
highs with daily cases now topping 4
000. the increase in severe cases is
absorbing medical resources with
concerns over a shortage of icu beds and
the diversion of attention from other
patients
the medical community is calling for
more robust measures
we need to live with covid19 and go back
to normal life by minimizing the damage
to protect the unvaccinated include
enforcing a strict vaccine pass and
strongly encourage the unvaccinated to
get vaccinated either by incentives
penalty or law
this week south korea approved more
emergency funds for small businesses but
angela's concern goes beyond her
finances
i'm worried
children are back to school but some
have not been vaccinated i don't think
corona will go away completely people
will have to practice stricter hygiene
and we'll just have to live with it
angela hopes more restrictions can be
avoided but she accepts the extra
challenges imposed on her business now
everyone else must do their part
or can we rely on that a paper in the
magazine nature found that well-timed
lockdowns can split the peak of
hospitalizations into two smaller
distant peaks while extending the
pandemic let's talk about that and other
measures with zirin binderman one of the
authors of that report
tell us more about your findings
hello
we
looked at the effectiveness
that different government restrictions
have had especially in the second wave
and the first wave and how that changed
over time
so for example
and we look at this across a whole range
of different countries
finding for example that it's been
effective to
restrict uh gatherings to a certain
number of people 10 or 100
that's been quite effective
but there was also also quite big
differences between the waves for
example
closing schools was one of the most
effective things to do
in terms of reducing transmission in the
first way but was less effective in the
second
and this sort of goes to show
the effect of safety measures
that reduce the extent of transmission
in schools so for example reducing class
sizes
means that if you now close a school
there's going to be lesson of an effect
because um
there's already less transmission
happening in that school in the first
place
and your paper mentioned reducing the
burden on hospitals but
uh lengthening the pandemic i mean i'm
sure that's not something anyone wants
to hear
a longer pandemic
um
yes i mean uh
could you clarify the question sure i
mean uh what what does it mean does how
much longer would we have to wait out if
we were to introduce measures like that
ah um
yeah i mean lengthening the pandemic
can be a good thing because it gives
vices more time to um
it's sort of the idea of flattening the
curve where
we prevent that hospitals become
overloaded
and so and then we can't provide good
care for patients anymore because
there's just too many in the hospital at
the same time
um
aside from that lengthening the pandemic
while keeping cases lower also
gives us more time to vaccinate people
and introduce develop better tests
cheaper tests uh so that
we can basically control the pandemic
more effectively okay so
that said and based on what you found
from uh your study what would you say
are the best measures for this fourth
wave
right um
so i think there's actually a lot of
similarity between between waves here so
as there are a lot of different measures
and we're not going to i can't go
through all of them but as a general
rule restrict uh the
measures that restrict the ability of
big groups of people to meet in indoor
spaces that's where we think most of the
transformation is happening and we've
learned that so slowly over time
this can make a lot of sense so this can
be
restricting hospitality or gastronomy
large gatherings um it can also mean
schools although
closing schools although
this is not going to be very popular at
the current time but you know in a
scenario where
uh where perhaps
omicron turns out to be
very transmissible and dangerous and
that scenario
could make sense again to do this
and then measures that also make a lot
of sense
for example
mask wearing
because
they are just it's just not a big cost
to society having to wear masks
there are also interventions that you
would say a good ones to keep beyond
this pandemic
it's an interesting question
well there's no
period perhaps there's no such thing as
beyond this pandemic because we're not
currently on the track to uh
to
bring the covert cases down to zero
but i think what's most important
actually beyond this pandemic is to
prepare for
potential new pandemics in the future
whether it may be soon or decades from
now
so being ready having having the
having the capacity to roll develop and
roll out a lot of testing quickly having
capacity to uh building the capacity to
produce vaccines quickly that was you
know that was a big bottleneck this time
and and to
uh and to quickly run the studies where
you have to put 30 000 people in a study
test the vaccine on them this took quite
some time although we sped it up it
could be even faster so i think that's
very important
thank you very much for being on the
show today
thank you
time for a viewer question and a good
one for the vaccinated and unvaccinated
over to derek williams
are there differences in the illness
when vaccinated and unvaccinated people
get covered 19
yep there are and and that's reflected
by a more fundamental factor which is
at this stage of the pandemic how likely
it is for a vaccinated person to test
positive for the virus
compared to an unvaccinated person um
the cdc in the u.s is tracking this
information and its most recent update
shows that unvaccinated people so the
black line are nearly six times more
likely to be diagnosed with a disease
than those who are fully vaccinated so
the blue line
and don't forget
that almost 60 percent of the population
there is fully vaccinated so that means
that well over four out of five cases of
covet 19 being detected in the u.s at
the moment
are occurring
in the 40 percent of the population
that's unvaccinated and the numbers grow
much starker when we compare
the average severity of the illness
between the two groups
an unvaccinated person in the u.s is
currently around 14 times more likely to
die from covet 19 than someone fully
vaccinated who has a breakthrough
infection in other words
that 40 percent of the us population
that's unvaccinated is counting over
nine in ten
deaths registered to the disease as well
as many many more
hospitalizations
several studies going more in depth into
symptom severity
showed that in the vaccinated the
chances of developing severe illness if
you're infected anyway
are reduced dramatically and
in the zoe covet study which tracks
things like types of symptoms
people with breakthrough infections have
mostly reported mild ones like those
that you have when you catch a cold so
things like a runny nose and sneezing
while unvaccinated people are more
likely to experience fever or a loss of
smell
in other words there's some overlap
between the two groups and exactly what
symptoms develop
but also some really important
differences particularly when it comes
to severity
you